you've agitated or angered one of the
supposedly Comus people on the planet
Deepak Chopra you you you ruffled his
feathers what did you do to get Deepak
Chopra so angry just I just tweeted some
fact I mean I've interviewed Deepak
Chopra many times and his whole thing as
always I do not get angry I if I'm in it
I've said to Deepak Chopra if you get
cut off in traffic are you ever angry at
that guy - no I feel sorry that he is in
pain spiritually you're not buying it he
tweeted to me I said something to him
joking about the origin of the universe
or something and he tweeted back saying
I'm going to shove my Cosmic
Consciousness up your ass he got very
annoyed with me and then he tweeted
something else and I said to him yeah
but you've got you I call him the
diamond-encrusted guru because when he
was um did he have his diamond then
Krishna he always wears I think we have
a photograph of him he always wears
glasses with with jewels on them I
noticed I called him that and you
bottomed the diamond encrusted granny
said it's not there rhinestones yeah he
said your rhinestone oh yeah I did tell
me did you feel that that was better or
worse I come back here someday
yeah probably I'm a bit next time just
give him a little just say yeah ask him
about the Schroedinger question so you
talk about quantum healing and these
things so solve the Schrodinger equation
in a spherically symmetric potential
first ask him to do that give me a
blackboard is a good slam you you
actually believe the biggest danger
facing humanity is stupidity right I got
a lot so why are you here
why this show Balto's I've got to warn
people about stupidity Souls you have to
go to the center where do the dumb
congregate yeah and in the sense that I
don't think we pay enough attention to
the wonderful things we've done
undiscovered so for example one of the
big threats to us we talk about threats
that can destroy civilization and
asteroid impacts is one of them sounds
like science fiction but it was with an
astronaut Carl rusty spy Gert actually
on Friday I've been up in San Francisco
we flew an Apollo 9 spend his time now
though trying to convince Congress and
the UN in those people to take this
seriously it's racking asteroids that
are headed our way
it's what is one example so that I
suppose the idea is that we have this
tremendous body of knowledge science
over the last three hundred and fifty
years has delivered the most terrific
wonderful view of the universe and now
it's about how seriously do we take that
yes if we if we take it seriously take
our survival seriously I admit that it's
in our own hands then I think use this
knowledge and don't like ostriches stick
our head in the sand and pretend that
things that scare us don't exist and do
homeopathy yeah it's not only up these
in big problem the entire problem but
right right these people have to accept
science homeopaths astrologers are mad
as well anyone else before you go meat
eaters
you